en france l'amiante va tuer cette année
près de 2000 personnes conclusion
sinistre d'un rapport d'experts de
l'inserm commandé par le gouvernement
sur les effets de ce matériau isolant
cancérigènes un rapport d'autant plus
inquiétant qu'il précise que tous les
types d'amiante sont dangereux et que
des catégories professionnelles que l'on
pensait à l'abri sont touchées en quête
mary pierce amitié florence vous tient
en amiante tu risques de cancer du
poumon mais aussi de la plèvre en
constante augmentation
l'exposition professionnelle à l'amiante
est aujourd'hui reconnue comme
dangereuse
y compris pour des professions qui
jusqu'à présent n'était pas considéré
comme un riff qu'il ya énormément
d'autres métiers qui sont
potentiellement concernés qui sont à
risques soit qu'il ya des risques réels
table aujourd'hui fonction très divers
des gens qui travaillent dans les
chemins de fer les garagistes de
bijoutiers des des dockers enfin une
liste extrêmement longue profession peut
être concernés dans la mesure où il ya
beaucoup d'amis en place dans beaucoup
d'endroits et que dans beaucoup de clubs
professionnels on est amené à intervenir
sur le métal aux critiques démunis de
toute information
ces personnes là ont donc pris des
risques pendant des dizaines d'années
parfois
ainsi ce chef d'atelier plombier
électricien il travaille tous les jours
depuis près de 20 ans au contact de
l'amiante à l'université de jussieu
protection oui et non pour vous dire
vrai non je n'avais pas été avec une
routine combien d'années pas loin d'un
dessin année
aujourd'hui vous avez des craintes
ajustements pour le bien sûr j'ai des
crânes j'ai des crânes aussi pour mes
collègues à jussieu les premiers
manifestants ont défilé contre l'amiante
dans les années 70 aujourd'hui soit 25
ans plus tard les experts de l'inserm
recommande une extrême vigilance pour
les expositions professionnelles